foreign they want everything just right
here
because it's tough selling electrical
Goods to a cash-strapped public
good afternoon holes Alison runs the
accounts here you don't see so many
people about nobody dare spend
nobody dare spend anything
and that's all down to the political
situation oh definitely
yeah they just need to sort it all out
struggling to get hold of stock with
some things yeah it's it's difficult
Chris's Grandad started this business in
the 1930s alongside his electricals
they're trying out a toy shop anything
to change their fortunes as the Prime
Minister changes again it affects
everybody in the UK it does everybody
and that's what they need to stop and
think about we must be the laughing
stock of the political world
we watched in the shop as it was all
confirmed as long as he gets on and
gets on with the job now and tries to
sort things out that's really what
matters
and whichever way your corner of the
country votes this cuts through every
community
you hear that frustration in cities
towns Villages even hamlets here in
rural middle England people have been
embarrassed by the circus in Westminster
and quite often they've suffered because
of it
[Music]
the day when the country found out it
would have its first British Asian prime
minister coincided with this
to all when he succeeded today even even
to the last moment I was thinking oh no
no he's not going to make it he's not
going to make it but then many did it it
just blew me out
Leicester always hosts one of the
biggest Diwali parties outside of India
it drew Rita here from Essex there's
people out there that are really really
struggling and obviously he's had a bit
of a privileged lifestyle I think he
needs to kind of be in touch yeah he's
the first Asian prime minister and he's
from a privileged background but he now
he really needs to be in touch with his
public because we're all now looking to
him for results
and that's the point the people now
living in sunax Britain won't accept
just more of the same
Tom Farmington Sky News leicestershire